di che cosa avevate paura da piccoli del
buio delle siringhe di quell'amica di
vostra madre con le unghie lunghe che
doveva per forza pizzicarvi le guance
Quando mi vedeva io ho paura di tutto
questo compresa dall'amica di mia madre
che esiste è vero La signora Porzia ma
c'era una cosa che mi faceva più paura
di tutte e quella cosa era mangiare Anzi
sedermi a tavola
tutto ebbe inizio all'asilo era una
bambina tranquilla non dovevamo mai
problemi però un giorno le maestre
convocano mia madre signora dicono le
maestre a mia madre tutto vero tutto
vero signora Abbiamo un problema sua
figlia mangia piano sua figlia ci
rallenta tutto il servizio mensa
mia madre prova una vergogna Ma una
vergogna tornò a casa disperata e iniziò
a fare caso come mangiamo in effetti io
mangiavo piano cioè mangiavo lentamente
ma no un'altra cosa mia madre mangiavo
tanta verdura ero diversa dagli altri
bambini
e quindi ogni volta che mi sedevo a
tavola mia madre mi implorava di
sbrigarmi ma è figlia mia sono del sud
me figlia mia mangia veloce mangiatele
delle patatine ogni tanto mangiati delle
merendine io non mangiavo patatine
merendine il mio piatto preferito è
tuttora l'insalata mia madre era
disperata continuava a essere disperata
si rivolse al medico al dottore Dottore
vero ripeto dottore mia figlia mangia
piano mia figlia mangia tanta insalata
come devo fare signora disse il dottore
signor Casamassima salutiamo anche lui
signora si rende conto le altre mamme
vengono qua disperate Perché i figli
mangiano veloci non mangiano la verdura
lei è fortunata signora
ero felice avevo la scienza dalla mia
parte ma mia madre no mia madre non era
felice mia madre non è mai stata felice
mia madre era sempre triste ansiosa
paranoica e non era un problema perché
vedete tutte le donne che avevo attorno
tutte le madri dei miei amici erano
tendenzialmente tristi erano
tendenzialmente ansiose erano
tendenzialmente paranoiche e soprattutto
tutte le donne adulte che conoscevo
erano madri faccio un'equazione tutte le
donne sono tristi tutte le madri sono
tristi
e ho pensato questa cosa per tutta la
mia vita fino a quando non sono andata a
studiare fuori sono andata a studiare a
Roma e conosciuto degli esseri
mitologici delle donne felici
addirittura delle madri felici madre che
non chiedevano i loro figli e le loro
figlie soltanto Hai mangiato Che cosa
hai mangiato quanto hai mangiato o no
chiedevano come è andato l'esame come
stai Come stanno i tuoi amici madri che
mandavano i loro figli coperte vestiti
madri che facevano bonifici ai loro
figli invece no noi del Sud a noi del
Sud arrivava il pacco da giù e che cosa
c'è nel pacco da giù cibo
focacce taralli l'olio buono Perché
l'olio al nord lo fanno male si sa ma
c'erano anche pasta biscotti Ma roba che
potevi trovare anche al supermercato
sotto casa
e però mi chiedevo a quel punto Ma
perché le donne che ho conosciuto io
quando ero piccola erano tristi perché
ci sono delle donne così tristi e delle
donne che invece sono felice
una risposta me l'ha data il femminismo
in particolare un libro che si chiama il
secondo sesso di Simon de bouvoir se non
conoscete questo libro i contenuti di
questo libro è normale perché le
studiose le femministe le filosofie a
scuola non te ne fanno leggere e quindi
eccomi qui a fare servizio pubblico per
voi amici del Ted e leggiamo insieme
qualche brano del secondo sesso in
particolare dei brani che riguardano le
casalinghe come mia madre probabilmente
come le vostre
pochi compiti dice deboys si avvicinano
al supplizio di Sisifo più di quello
della Massaia giorno per giorno bisogna
lavare i piatti spolverare rammendare
tutte cose che domani saranno di nuovo
sporco polvero si è rotte e dopo guarda
dice cucinare è una cosa bellissima è un
atto anche creativo
le donne devono andare per esempio fuori
casa vanno al mercato ma cade sottolinea
che come per i lavori domestici la
ripetizione di queste cose pone fine ben
presto a questi piaceri la cosa più
triste è che questo lavoro non porta
neanche una creazione durevole
ma in realtà tutto contribuisce a far sì
che le massaie siano infelici
e siano rabbiose perché questo il succo
del secondo sesso molte donne non
scelgono il loro destino il loro destino
gli viene imposto soltanto per il fatto
di essere femmina e questo contribuisce
a rendere tristi rabbiose un'altra
definizione molto calzante rispetto alla
situazione in cui sono cresciuta la dà
Elena Ferrante non sappiamo la sua
identità probabilmente una donna del sud
ma comunque una persona che le donne del
sud le conosce molto bene e scrive nel
primo libro dell'amica geniale lo
leggiamo che questo insieme sempre
perché le scrittrici a scuola
difficilmente le trovate non ho
nostalgia delle mie infanzia è pieno di
violenza far male era una malattia da
bambina mi sono immaginata animali
piccolissimi quasi invisibili che
venivano di notte nel rione uscivano
dagli stagni dalle carrozze ed entravano
nell'acqua nel cedro delle nostre mamme
delle nostre nonne rendendole rabbiose
come cagna assetate Erano contaminate
più degli uomini perché i maschi
diventavano furiosi di continuo Ma alla
fine si calmavano mentre le femmine che
erano all'apparenza silenziosi
accomodanti quando si arrabbiavano
andavano fino in fondo alle loro furie
senza fermarsi più
quella furia e quella di cui parla Simon
de Bear nel secondo sesso lo so cosa
state pensando vabbè Questo è un romanzo
ambientato Negli anni cinquanta e Simon
beauvoir era una scrittrice filosofa Sì
ma dell'inizio del Novecento metà
Novecento le cose sono cambiate ed avete
ragione le cose sono cambiate però non
sono cambiate così in fretta e del tutto
ora lasciamo perdere i miei traumi
lasciò perdere mia madre che ne sarà
contenta Lasciamo perdere I filosofi
Lasciamo perdere le scrittrici
affidiamoci i dati
quelli che vi farò vedere sono diretti
recenti Eh niente Storia sono dati
dell'anno passato o dell'anno in corso e
ci dicono delle cose
le donne al sud sono occupate solo per
il 33%, la metà più o meno rispetto al
dato del centro nord Italia e
dell'Europa dell'Unione Europea
solo il 43% delle madri questo è una
media nazionale sono occupate e il 63%
delle donne al sud sono disoccupati Anzi
delle mamme al sud sono disoccupate
questo perché avviene perché le donne
storicamente tradizionalmente
culturalmente sono destinate al lavoro
di cura e molto spesso non riescono a
conciliare queste due cose
e altrettanto spesso non vengono
incentivate quando sono bambine a
coltivare i loro interessi le loro
passioni banalmente a studiare
e le donne con un livello di istruzione
basso sono quelle che hanno più
difficoltà a trovare lavoro voi starete
pensando Si vabbè ma quante saranno le
donne che non Studiano nel nostro paese
3 milioni sono le donne in Italia che
non hanno un diploma che non hanno
finito la scuola superiore e sono le
donne che poi fanno più fatica a trovare
lavoro ha un lavoro ben pagato un lavoro
specializzato
e molto spesso anzi quasi nella totalità
dei casi le donne devono ricorrere al
part-time involontario cioè vorrebbero
lavorare di più vorrebbero coltivare le
loro carriere ma fanno difficoltà a
conciliare il lavoro di cura e lavoro in
casa e lavoro fuori casa sono donne per
la maggior parte solo il 7,2% dei maschi
degli uomini ricorre al part time
involontario
ovviamente quando Noi leggiamo i dati
sulla disoccupazione sulle donne che
riescono a fatica a conciliare lavoro
fuori casa lavoro in casa Beh Dobbiamo
pensare sempre che nel sud Italia è
peggio
Insomma è passato tanto tempo dai
racconti di Elena Ferrante ma non così
tanto evidentemente però vedete in
effetti le cose cambiano nel nostro
paese sapete tutti che l'Italia sta
affrontando quello che alcuni
definiscono un inverno demografico si
fanno meno figli e la famiglia
tradizionale e in crisi sono
33,2% delle famiglie puoi essere
composte da una sola persona Dai single
in Europa siamo 8,5 milioni e siamo
destinati a crescere
Inoltre Chi decide di unirsi non lo fa
sposandosi Infatti sono sempre di più i
bambini i bambini e le bambine che
nascono fuori dal matrimonio questo
metterà in crisi l'industria dei
matrimoni Soprattutto quelli pugliesi
che come sapete possono durare anche 12
ore
questi dati che cosa ci portano a dire
Beh l'Istat ha fatto delle previsioni
per il 2050 manca pochissimo 30 anni E
cosa ci dicono queste previsioni
che i decessi nel 2050 in Italia saranno
il doppio delle nascite in sintesi lo
leggete da soli Ci saranno sempre più
anziani e sempre meno bambini ci saranno
sempre più persone che andranno in
pensione e sempre meno persone che
quella pensione gliela pagheranno almeno
per come è concepito Lo Stato Sociale il
Welfare nel nostro paese
La famiglia sta cambiando
e questo comporta delle cose comporta
soprattutto il fatto che la famiglia
cambia perché oggi sempre più donne
possono scegliere chi essere
sempre più donne per esempio trovano
difficoltà a conciliare il lavoro la
carriera col fatto di essere madre e
questo le rende tristi le rende triste
perché come cantava Tiziano Ferro il
mondo va veloce e tu stai indietro e per
tu Intendo la società per come è stata
concepita ed è concepita oggi vedete
molti leggono questi dati in maniera
allarmistica Però come tutte le
questioni Anzi quasi tutte c'è un
rovescio della medaglia Appunto ci sono
sempre più donne libere disceglie e se
sono libere di scegliere e anche grazie
ad attiviste a politiche a filosofi e a
scrittrici come si mondo beauvoir e
Elena Ferrante e la famiglia è vero Si
sfalda ma forse si sfalda la famiglia
come l'abbiamo conosciuta fino adesso
una famiglia che era costretta a sedersi
attorno a un tavolo a mangiare
tutto
legata dai legami di sangue oggi la
famiglia non tutti e non tutte vero ma
si può scegliere e le famiglie sono
diverse sono uno spettro di identità
e ci sono sempre più uomini che aiutano
in casa sempre più donne che non sanno
cucinare perché non sono tenute a farle
è sempre più uomini che invece si
dilettano ai fornelli
sono famiglie nuove famiglie con cui
stiamo imparando a convivere molto
probabilmente facciamo parte di una di
quelle famiglie allargate che si
riuniscono attorno a un tavolo e vedete
Se c'è una cosa che ci hanno insegnato
queste scrittrici queste filosofie che
una donna si può nutrire di tante cose e
può nutrire a sua volta di tante cose di
cibo ovviamente
ma anche di amore e anche di libertà
probabilmente ci attende un futuro in
cui le donne saranno sempre più libere e
in cui le madri le nonne
impareranno che oltre a chiederci hai
mangiato potranno chiederci Come stai
e sempre più donne che impareranno a
dire i loro figli ai loro figli che
voglio bene ti voglio bene mamma Grazie